we're back you know we missed a week
and i think we all felt that i was
really sad i think that's
set me into the depression i'm currently
in that i'm telling you but i really do
think because i was
i was so glam i got up at 6 00 a.m i was
ready at 9 a.m and then at 9 9am you're
like
are somebody's aunt somebody tested for
covet and i was like
well go get tested right now you guys
are like the king and queen of getting
tested in 15 minutes
yeah but it's not the thing is like it's
still not
safe if if if i just found out that
someone in my bubble has
been infected it you're supposed to
quarantine for like you know 10 days but
it was a bubble of someone in your
bubble
it was someone else's bubble it was my
housekeeper's sister
right tested positive so i was like oh
[ __ ] that you know
yeah so i we canceled all of our plans
for the whole week it was awful you know
it was horrible
and i i i was very i was very sad too
that we had
and today we almost had to cancel again
because our power was out okay two weeks
in a row i've had
really great outfits planned and i
already got glam and everything i was
already in this when you were gonna
cancel again and i was like
that's why you're like we might do it
tomorrow i'm like no i got my red itself
ready today
and you know what was especially sad is
that we have such a fun
fantastic episode planned to the tea
and you know listen i don't get i don't
have much in life
and i've never mooked being let alone
with a fondue set
where'd you get this we're gonna mooc
bang together that sounds sexy maybe
can we do a naked mush bang for only
fans after
that is like the most unattractive thing
i can imagine
kitties out and everything everything
pantless
why do people pay why would people pay
to see that
they can watch it now because no one's
seen it from you they want to see the
people i think people
oh they want to see my penis while they
eat cheese
oh it's a thing you think people would
pay to see my penis i know
people would do you know who nicotto
avocado is yeah he does that on only
fans yeah but he does weird wild stuff
he like [ __ ]
does gaping [ __ ] porn and he makes
like so much money like six figures off
only fans
god i can't imagine paying to see victor
cardo's gaping [ __ ]
yeah your surprise is better i think you
would make more money
i think you're more attractive than a
cacado yeah but i wouldn't go as far as
he does you know what i mean
yeah like just my dick handling out i
mean nobody wants to see that
i would i'd pay five dollars what about
20.
if i'm in it too yeah 20.
let's let's see let's do a hard left
turn
um congrats on the success of teddy
fresh
thank you i didn't know it was so poppin
why do you say that
me and uh moses were at free people in
manhattan beach and we walked in and
they're supposed to wear free people
outfits
and she was wearing a teddy fresh outfit
the employee and i'm like aren't you
supposed to be wearing free people she's
oh i try to sneak in people
free people is like a huge overpriced
store it's like really trendy it's like
300 for a t-shirt and we went in there
and she was wearing teddy fresh free
about that
sounds like enslaved people to me you
have the worst jokes although i miss
these jokes
i was so sad i honestly like cried last
week that i didn't get to see you
every person in my thousand dollar
outfit
well it's more free like hippie free
that's like they're like a hippie vibe
like that's their free people
i can't afford that [ __ ] yeah the bougie
ones can like jared leto
yeah jared is more of a [ __ ] freak
cult
jared little's such a freak why because
he's got like a cult
dude he found some next theme [ __ ] i
want to go i heard about it on your
on the other podcast and i was like oh i
want to go there i was going to go
to croatia okay before we get started
with this first of all thank you to adam
and eve for sponsoring this episode
thank you for getting me off this
morning i squirted with their egg this
morning
let's wait we'll talk we'll give them
all the love in the world in about 30
minutes and i also want to say
trisha and i'm i'm sorry i know you're
not going to like this but i'm having a
teddy because you can be like why are
you promoting your own [ __ ] in our show
even though you do it all the time
okay it's fair enough yeah thank you
fair enough fair enough teddy fresh
black friday sale 30 to 50 off
everything
go ahead head on over to teddyfresh.com
and see if there's anything good you
like there because it's 30 to 50 percent
off we're doing black friday for the
whole month of november because [ __ ]
2020. what a coincidence online.com is
also doing black friday the whole month
except
it's one dollar for the entire oh i
thought it was free you went you raised
the price it was only free for election
day
wow you raised the price you've changed
it's always five dollars but now it's
one dollar for black friday so only
trish.com
you really have changed all right let's
get to the cheese
i've got like so much i want to talk
about but i feel like we should just get
to the cheese because the only thing is
you eat and hot you like them that's
what the mukbang is which parts muk and
which parts bang
what do you mean it's a korean word
there's no there's no separation of the
words it's mukbang
what does mukbang mean eating show
korean for eating
oh it just means eating yeah all right
well i cook some steaks so let's get
those out before they
go rotten and i don't need any help
having diarrhea tonight so let's not eat
rotten meat okay you're
so disgusting dude i'm sorry you're the
girl talking about cheese in your
[ __ ] because we have adam and eve
today oh you made this yeah
oh my god it's like a date you cook
dinner for me wow
i feel so special it's not a day you
don't do that you usually order pizza i
see your tic tacs you're like we're
gonna order pizza tonight oh i cook
really i don't know ask you that she's
here oh you're here today hi
does he cook really oh we both get two
or more fat [ __ ] monster we each get
two
to
first of all that's not a lot trigger
warning to people with eating disorders
damn that's like not a lot
eating disorder wait do people with
eating orders eating disorders get
trigger warnings
yeah i think a warning to uh anorexic
people we are going to be eating a milk
thing
and then do we trigger warning to obese
people too what's the word
trigger warning same thing like eating
like binge eating all that stuff is like
people with eating disorders
trigger warning you're gonna like this
video okay so here
so we're trying to recreate you guys all
seen the viral vid of the
asian mukbanger dude who [ __ ] did a
explosive cheese so
so here this we're gonna see if this one
works exactly
zach oh zak troy i love zak toy okay
here we go
oh
so we're trying to replicate the zak
choi oh
this is the destructive cheese and then
we're gonna see if we can
oh is it gonna fountain over well it's
supposed to right oh
i've never seen this i've never seen
this where'd you see that what do you
mean
i've never seen this before what what's
happening because it's not fountaining
over
no but i see it i see it um like it's in
the pipes it wants to get there
come on sucker come on now bye
get up that pipe now boy wow yeah
oh get in that pipes baby
all right dip dip your uh wait we dip
the steak dip
[Laughter]
this is a wait why is it doing that
i think it's bad i think it's not
working oh my god open your mouth
open your mouth
oh i missed it it's not going out
you just got it what if i choke on it
here get it in there trisha
[Music]
i gotta get closer get in there
this is some only fan [ __ ] right here
come on catch it
oh my god everything's hot oh my god i
got the cheese on me
okay
i
so i mean it kind of tastes good should
i put on the steak what we're doing no
we have an issue is everyone okay
okay well the thing is going okay the
cheese is good though
how do we do did you put the cheese on
it okay we turned it off
was that good oh yeah so here so here
would you want do you want some
yum i put some on i put some cheese
and you came from your hands well what
can you do it's a mukbang did you wash
them
no okay
[Music]
the steak is cold i don't mind it you
like that
wow i mean it's a lot it tastes like
cheese
it's pretty good y'all i mean i'm not
gonna hate on it
i think it's really good i think there's
not enough cheese on it like
my ideal bite is like that take the
whole thing like that
like just that part what if one of us
dies tonight have a hard time
probably i mean the show will go good i
guess i could sue you
because i'm under age three man
moses might how about trigger warning
before judy's been sued before
for what you've been two before you lost
or win
i won oh that's scary that's
intimidating onto itself
i think like a napkin oh i have one
under the big finger hold on so i just
realized that this whole show is just
gonna be us munching in the microphone
and getting them is that why people oh
well it's disgusting because i'm sitting
here going i like it
can you see how [ __ ] gross the table
is okay
it's so gross such a vibe for the video
though
right it's gross people it's just such a
fun the name of the podcast should be
two gross people
like that disgusting first of all i've
lost weight i'm no longer fat i'm under
200 pounds now
what did you lose i lost three pounds
hey i'm still under 200. what are you
2.9 am i under 200 what does it look
like
kind of what does this look like you're
just very skinny in your shoulders i
i have very broad shoulders you have
very skinny shoulders so you look skinny
kind of iconic was this good though you
did good on the steak
cheese
i love this steak you did so good on it
[Laughter]
all right well oh there's cheese all
over the mic too looking at you
e is like watching my selfie and it kind
of repulses me
it's kind of gross like why people watch
my mukbangs they're like well to be
honest i don't think i can eat more
steak
i'm like done but i'll wait for you i
have questions for you if you want to we
can get the next course if you want to
finish that finish that i'm going to
feed you i'm going to take the royal
feeder
i knew you were into this okay yeah look
at my wife i'm super undefeated
she's like oh my god trigger warning for
skinny people out there some people
might be
triggered okay i want to show you a
video since i've got you in your most
vulnerable spot eating
[ __ ] steak and cheese it's good
good i'm glad you like my steak i take
my steak cooking very seriously yeah i'm
surprised
why does that surprise you i don't know
i'm so out of it oh my god okay i've got
a question
yeah you claim that you don't know what
i a lot of people go does trisha play up
her like ignorance with like the
holocaust and climate change and mm-hmm
i i personally flip-flop between
yes and no people by the way said you
didn't know climate change because you
didn't explain it to me everyone i
talked to was like even
ethan didn't even know you didn't give
me a chance you start you want to know
climate changes
do you want me to do no i'm over climate
change that's what i mean what do you
want me to do
you go what does it mean that you i
would start talking about climate change
and you go oh what's going to happen if
the ice melts
i was like well like millions of people
will be displaced
climate change is when there's a bunch
of greenhouse gases in the atmosphere
and so
it's causing the it's causing the globe
to heat up from man-made oh my god
nobody wants to hear about this don't
you read it you're heating up and
and and uh weather is changing it makes
hurricanes worse it makes fires worse it
just makes
all the all the uh you know all the
climate uh phenomenon it's more extreme
okay i mean what do you want nobody
wants don't you care that we're in a
like a
100 year drought in california that's
part of climate change okay what's the
question
and they even say that europe could
freeze over as a result of climate
change so it's not just eating the globe
well you say that you were like oh ethan
you don't know what climate change is
you basically challenged me to [ __ ]
you didn't waste 10 minutes of this
podcast on that i just want you
i picked
[Applause]
did you eat this cheese if i chewed it
up and spit it out would you put it in
your mouth what if i chewed it up and
spit it into your mouth
why would you do it for like a thousand
dollars no i would do it for a thousand
dollars i wouldn't do it for ten
thousand
really no you think i have like
something wrong with me no it's just
disgusting i wouldn't do it for anyone i
don't think it's that disgusting i love
being fed like a baby bird when people
chew stuff up and spit in my mouth
i think it's hot okay let's get back to
the point oh my god i've been saying
that i hate this
you say that you don't know what the
what do you want to be
how much more do you want to talk about
being fed like a baby bird oh okay i'm
down what did i do that i'm controlling
the pace okay let's talk about what you
want to talk about go ahead and talk
more about being fed like a baby bird go
ahead i'll wait here and listen
i was trying to stop you from climate
change but you got to keep going keep
i'm not talking
i'm just moving on to the next thing
okay i'm ready you said you don't know
what the holocaust is
yet in a video from 2012 you said this
if you guys
see my video the 20 things you didn't
know about me you guys know i'm really
big into like holocaust literature so
probably
[ __ ] does that mean i never said i
didn't know what the holocaust was by
the
way
wait why did you say 12 things you don't
know about me i'm really into holocaust
literature i like reading about jesus
what book
what book have you read about the
holocaust i used to have a book of jew
and it literally was a book of jews yeah
it's a real book look it up about amazon
book of jews i think and it goes through
all the important
like historical events is it called the
old testament by chance
no it's called i just said it in my tic
tac today what is it it's like uh
picky albert pekita wait how can you say
in 2012 that you are into holocaust
literature but then fast forward from
two weeks ago you're like
wait hitler did what first of all i
didn't know the extremity of hitler i
just like i didn't know
i didn't know what it was really i just
knew it was a jew thing
and i didn't really understand what it
was until we watched schindler's list
half of schindler's list half of
schindler's list well i had to stop
because i didn't realize i didn't
realize what it was
i just knew it was a jew thing lots of
jews died let me get this straight you
couldn't
finish schindler's list because it made
you so uncomfortable
yeah imagine how the jews felt
and you can't even finish schindler's
list well those were
old time juice why do we always talk
about jews i get in so much trouble and
take right now
next dish next
ah this is so exciting oh can i get the
uh can we get the liquid cheese out here
yeah well can we not do something that
spins around i really want to catch one
in my mouth i thought i would have been
so sick i'm sorry
can i throw this in your mouth open your
mouth open your mouth
no i'm not a dog
oh you could have caught it wait do you
want more two more okay
let me get lower you want like a curve
or a straight shot curve
oh no we gotta aim higher okay here
i know i can get one in my mouth okay
[Laughter]
oh my god oh my god this is the littlest
pretzel ever
all right it's just a mess over here
all right it's just gonna do the same
thing this one is supposed to work
so here we go you ready everybody in my
hair thank you baby
please work oh no it's pretty stringy
you guys
oh it looks hot too it looks scary
because it's like warm does this work
okay
ah wow
okay that feels a little too thick still
doesn't it i love it
maybe just pour some milk on top yeah no
it's like heated
i think that you see that yeah that
doesn't look right that looks disgusting
it's supposed to be like a beautiful
fountain
really okay let's go cheers oh my god i
love a cheers okay
are you gonna cheers me or no okay i
love that
you like it it's a little i like it okay
i should have potato in it but other
than that it's good you mean like
what do you mean potato like you you you
like just mix like
boiled potatoes yeah like a boiled
potato in there this is actually so good
what do we think is this working i mean
kind of we just
put a dash of milk yeah
just get it around like maybe on this
side too dan you made this
yeah wow well we just mixed cheese and
milk so
i didn't realize you couldn't see dan on
the show people are like because on
yours they see him right now they don't
know who dan is some of the people yeah
people like who did you talk to and i
was like oh i thought you could see him
so weird so you know how we always joke
about this is the worst i feel like this
is the worst episode
why because we're just because it's like
look at this isn't it right it's just
munching and
okay i think i think i mean this looks
really disgusting it has looked like
this
i think it's good yeah i don't think it
looked like it looked like exactly what
that's kind of diarrhea yeah
like look at the chunks come cascading
down don't ruin it there's no elegance
about that
that was supposed to be elegant you're
so gross all right bring a funny one
bring one that's interesting prick
pretzel not interesting
well whatever
oh my god bring the next dish why are
you so hyped
you're so hyped today i have to command
oh my god thank you this is one i
thought would be interesting
i love fruit loops it's a bowl of fruit
loops
we're gonna do cereal with cheese
you're just going for the fruit loops
you don't even care about the cheese
we're going to use the cheese as milk oh
okay i love that
so let's just take a scoop
and then a big old thing of cheerios oh
my god
yeah this one i'm not too excited about
get ready
cheers oh that's
not bad that ain't right because i i
just want to be eating fruit loops but
that this is [ __ ]
i like the fruit it's abomination of god
oh my god this is
who i've got oh god wow this is worse
than the holocaust
you're not supposed to say his name i
found out if you're jewish g
you're not supposed to say yahweh well
yahweh is the acronym
because you're not supposed to you can
say yahweh right oh you know
[Laughter]
i hate it you hate it but you're still
eating it well
yeah the nature of the beast in there um
are we talking about today or no we're
just doing eating show cause did you i
feel like did you see the awesome
mcgregor jake paul thing
you're so stupid why are you over it no
i just think that they're they're
friends
they're just faking it oh you're not
into the fake fights
i mean i think they're faking the beef
right would you bite awesome
groom no why you you're such a he's such
a whip
i am really i feel like you're a fighter
would you fight me in a boxing match
wrestling
andy kaufman style he used to wrestle
woman you're taking a lot of bites of
that
it's all good actually oh my god loki
should we wrestle for like charity that
would be pretty
that would be pretty amazing maybe for a
charity event yeah i wrestled
i wonder if we should sell out like the
staples center just for a big ass
wrestling ring
oh yeah you could do that you're busy
just buy it out
you know what i mean you're like my rich
brother that i come to visit
and they feed me
[Laughter]
here you go little there you go here's
your froot loops and
cheese cereal oh i miss you you're so
sweet
you're literally the nicest person i've
ever met yeah
okay oh do you see megan is missing or
we go to the next thing here
you want you want me to ask you stuff no
it's asking you did you see megan is
missing i don't know who that is who's
making this video oh my god
who's megan it's a huge netflix thing
right now you didn't hear about it they
use like found footage of like
i don't want to spoil it for anyone but
it's it was like a real story it was
like trending on twitter last night
i never even heard of it it's like that
next the netflix phenomenon where your
homepage is dramatically different than
other people's you know
based on what you know like sometimes
there's shows
on netflix that everyone's talking about
that i never even heard of
i think we need more milk because this
is just this is the
this is sad i thought it was good i
think i think
if we can just like mix up the milk i
don't know if it needs more milk but i'm
just gonna mix it up here
you know what milk is bringing the milk
bring in the milk it's from a cow on the
bottom
milk from a cow wait did you say milks
from macau yeah
so tell me about why you said that
i have water oh yeah fill me up thank
you why did you say milks from a cow
it is what it's it's the plus of a cow
uh it's the pus it's it's the puss of a
cow
and human breast smoke what about it is
it also the pus
of a female honestly
no so what's the difference i don't know
how does you think about it how does a
woman create it yeah maybe it is they
don't get zits around the pregnancy time
maybe it is plus
it's fun chicken nuggets it's it's uh
sorry i got so excited all right bring
it in
so wait are you you telling me that um
no good
that cow milk that milk is from cows
implies that you did
there was a point recently where you
didn't know that cow pus
yeah but it's not cow [ __ ] it is cow oh
you want chicken nuggets are we doing
chicken nuggets because i do know we're
chicken
what do you mean cow puss like you know
it's like milk you know like all mammals
they lactate that's that's part of what
it means to be a mammal
even called these are so good these hit
so hard
oh my god i mean let's do cheese i'm
down with cheese on this too yeah let's
go
you know what chicken nuggets are you
know it wasn't where do you know what
they like what they're made out of
like chicken girl yeah yeah like bone
and [ __ ]
yeah it's like all the part of the
chicken that you don't eat you know what
can i say something like a beet yeah
it doesn't gross me out i think it's
beautiful though they do
they don't go exactly like you're able
to use these eyeballs and [ __ ]
skin and bones it's like i'm supposed to
be grossed out with that
i think it's amazing that you can use
these parts of the animals we don't want
into this beautiful delicious little
[ __ ] do you have nuggets fall of
death do you like it yeah like nugs
do you let your study would you let your
son eat it no you're gonna get fast food
yeah really i think so wow i think it's
important to
to um introduce them to everything so
that they
cause like my parents were really
restrictive about what i could eat
really
and everyone i know who has really
restrictive parents they end up fat like
me
mine weren't restricted i ate mcdonald's
my whole life
well and then there's people like you
well i think the childhood trauma made
me fat to be honest because i kept
eating i still cook with eating which is
why i'm getting away because i'm
depressed right now i mean i didn't lose
three pounds but i think that's when i
was happy like two weeks ago
this looks disgusting right like it's
supposed to look better than this right
no i think it looks cool
i'll try and catch it the way you're
supposed to i don't even know how you're
supposed to catch it yeah because it's
supposed to be more liquidy but
okay these are so good all right get rid
of the nuggets
nuggets be gone pickles why did you give
up on tick-tock
i didn't give i just i've been posting i
posted some
you know i love this guy he's my
favorite the yellow eyes who goes i
never seen two
pretty best friends yeah one of them
always got it that one did good for you
because i checked your views for you
yeah that one did really good yeah i
love that guy me too
oh do you like pickles i hate pickles
but i'll eat it but i hate them
i i don't mind it but i don't like these
thick boys i like my little
microphone this isn't only fans all
right everybody get your dicks out
this is it this is definitely the worst
episode we've ever done and
and i say that with peace and love i
imagine yours look like that
you think i've got like would you
consider that like a child yeah or like
a normal that's normal what is that five
inches
what do you think how does it compare to
this
i feel like i'm packing more heat than
this yeah really
oh cause that's girthy well that's
that's a thick one either just said i'm
packing more heat
congrats thank you only fans thank you
i was hoping you would ride for me but i
wasn't quite sure what you would say oh
my god her brother is in this room and
you're talking about your sex with him
oh my god the [ __ ] that you [ __ ] say
about your brother like how dare you
even bring that
up freak well usually ela's not in the
room i wouldn't talk about sex in front
of her whatever who cares
yeah i got a fat one no i don't
ugh oh ew and when i pee this is what it
looks like
yo where's your pickle oh you want me to
do it too i really don't want to damn
well that's not bad actually why did you
slobber like you don't have to like spit
me too but it's just disgusting
everything's disgusting
i don't like this i don't like this
mukbang [ __ ]
well i think we made it wrong
with the cheese i had some made last
week for us and you cancelled
it looks good up until like this point
and then this starts to get like really
not right
thanks
[Laughter]
um did you take a bite of the pickle or
did you yeah what the [ __ ] bring the
pickle back
can i have his i want to eat off his
pickle
ew why guys that's kind of everything
that's
no don't eat the don't eat from my
pickle why
honestly i love tasting people's like
spit to be honest
you know i can't believe you ate the
[ __ ] my pickled
[ __ ] that's amazing
like i actually thought that's probably
my favorite but i've still not
spit it out no i mean of all the [ __ ]
i've eaten here today the pickle
you eat [ __ ] okay what's this that's
just a mild pepper
these should be bigger like the banana
boats on tick-tock that people eat
what oh no
why we're gonna like die it's a spicy
pep it's a habanero
happy new year okay you don't think so
yet
well we'll keep it here these are full
these are full
fresh habaneros this is so fun
oh i hate sushi
what is this baby i wrapped it up what's
his idea thank you
california what does that mean is it
crab or is it fake crab
fake crab you don't eat sushi no i don't
like it wait why did you get this then
is it baby got it i mean i'm just
i'm here for you know i'm trying
everything i love it
so this is just there's not even seafood
in this fake crab
kind of [ __ ] oh it has fish in it
okay let's get our diarrhea on yeah
we'll stop saying that before we eat
hmm is it everything as you say
it's not everything no but it's some
things
but it's not hot your feet are not
getting hot
it's [ __ ] no it's not
i mean none of the stuff we're eating is
hot so it kind of goes with it i
actually like that
well really i think that's good
yeah you gotta have gotten like sugar
fish but the
for this stupid [ __ ] bit check your
face there's gonna be 20 highlights of
this
you can spend the highlight money on the
sushi sugar fish for this
yeah i thought it was pretty good
actually of all the [ __ ] we've eaten
here yeah
whole foods oh step up
all right we'll do a quick break here
just thank adam and uh eve and then
we'll come back and do the whole thing
what i said adam and eve should we do it
in unison like
ready thank you everybody that adam and
we tried that
sucks i don't want to get adam and eve
you want to do this because you're like
the adam and eve
uh ambassador really truly
yeah i've been on doing it for six years
go ahead all right
guys today's frenemies is sponsored by a
friend not enemy of the show adam and
eve adamnev.com
you can get anything slash h3 no
hd at checkout use the code h3 at
checkout
if you use the code you'll get 50 off
any single item plus free shipping if
you are in the us and canada and what's
super special about this podcast code h3
as you can't get with any other
influencer
is you get 10 free gifts plus six spicy
movies
jump in wherever you want we are hitting
every yeah you get them for her you get
it for him you get it for
couples together how much is shipping
it's free if you use h3 at checkout
and um may i recommend the uh
g-spot the hulk finger g-spot destroyer
oh this is amazing especially if you
have fingernails i don't know if we can
show this but we'll
we'll blur it it's not a dildo i mean
it's a huge pink finger
it's a huge pink finger i'll hide it
behind the cheese thing don't put it so
close to me please this is the best part
about the giant finger that vibes on
your g-spot it vibes on your g-spot so
it also hits your [ __ ] energy spot at
the same time
giving an orgasm every single time
guaranteed but it's only guaranteed if
you use the code h3 and then you get
that guaranteed orgasm
so go to atomy.com use code h2o wait is
adam and eve guaranteeing an orgasm
or your money back i'm i'm guaranteeing
if you use the code and get the giant
finger because it will hit your g-spot
and clitoris at the exact same moment
it's kind of amazing like it actually is
amazing i'm not just saying that like
not to plug whatever but if i go to my
other sites where i do this you'll see
every single time it hits within three
they really need to put like a
fingernail on it to make it look you
know what i mean like that's the whole
point not you because i have these in
this hurry i know i know but like why do
they have the engineer fingernail on it
because it feels like a real finger
but like i'm just saying why make it
look like a giant freak finger you want
to just feel flash like you want it to
feel like i know but the shape
is fine you don't need a fingernail on
it you know what i mean
no you do that's the whole point
otherwise it's just a vibe it's just a
vibe up in there
so you just have like a little indention
of a fingernail and here there's the
digits right there so it's like a real
finger
okay it's flashlight it's amazing
atomy.com use code h350 off plus free
shipping if you're in the usa help
support the show it's frenemies you guys
love it they pay
they get us paid because like i mean
this [ __ ] look at this
look at this budget no this is the
highlights budget because you
ours is split adam and eve the
highlights you put towards this you said
what yeah you said you had to do the
highlights for production cards are we
doing an ad are we [ __ ]
arguing about our revenue calm is
amazing please keep sponsoring us i
truly love you i get orgasms
code h3 use code h3o thank you everybody
okay so bring out the next thing we are
trying to keep our
cheese it's not keeping the cheese hot
right
so yeah this is getting collect like
more and more
progressively disgusting hot milk in
there yeah we just throw hot milk in
we're trying to liquefy it and just
this is really tough times eh yeah
what's the a you said that three times
there you canadian today
oh yeah baby let [ __ ] go
okay okay okay there's a dog there i
don't know what this is what is this do
you know which one this is that's all
mozzarella is it blue or black
it's just hot corn dog what do you mean
blue or black there's no on the bottom
stick oh it's black
i think it's all mozzarella it's hard to
tell
why am i doing this is so gross i'm so
excited this is my fave
yeah mozzarella that's mom
that's it oh this is hotter up here i
think
what's the yellow moon um it might be a
sausage in it
what's the nothing meme i think that's
just all mozzarella there might be a
sausage in yours
at the bottom i think it's all moss
hmm i want that one i hate
sausage it's a hot dog what do you mean
sausage i like just the all korean i
like the all mozzarella but it's a hot
dog it's not a sausage you know what's
the difference is
what's the difference i don't know i
don't eat either one's a hot dog one's a
sausage i'm jewish i don't eat pork
hmm
oh it was all good why would anyone
watch this like like i mean the mukbang
thing of people like this is a moving
right like we're doing a movie
then why would people watch this i
actually helped with eating disorders
people who don't want to eat alone
and they eat with you really mm-hmm so
we're saints
we're both offending and helping the
eating disorder
people that's fine
that's good i wish we could get them
fresh you could get the cheese pull
you always eat them like this because
when you had them before you say why
does this one look like it's a fish
octopus or squid there's questions oh
there's
hot dog in this too where's me this is
all mozzarella
um what is that
oh my god oh my god show that to the
camera it's like
putrid it's like full on mozzarella
popsicle
all right is this the this is the rice
cake one isn't it
that's what your veins are gonna look
like oh i feel like
you're veins i know every day i feel
like i'm about to have a hard time
what's this [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
okay that's really good tastes like
french fries on it
oh no i'll split it with you
oh no there's a sausage in there too i
just like all cheese
this is this this ain't right
this is so good yum this is our favorite
place to go me and moses so we go here
on our dates tub
you like it which one do you like
just cheese no [ __ ] and he eats the
hot dogs too sometimes but he likes all
she's better
wait smell like [ __ ] you never said your
nickname for ela can you just say it now
no why i don't say it it's embarrassing
what is it
i'm not telling you you can tell them no
i won't tell anybody
why not i just told you it's very
personal like i watch your podcast
and it's always like you complaining
about politics i'm worried about covet
and that's it
it's never like oh today we you know had
sex in you know
the play room or something you know it's
never like personal you're looking for
sexual anecdotes but
yeah we don't share a lot of sexual
anxiety okay what about just like you
dates you guys go on
like oh we wait for the kid we don't go
on dates you didn't want a date you went
to the hotel
yeah we talked about that whatever you
watch all of our podcasts
no i can get through five minutes and
i'm like oh i can't what's that so you
don't know what you're talking about no
i read the comments
you just read the comments you just want
to see people sitting on me
it makes me feel better about my comment
section really it's that bad
yeah i'm like my own people don't hate
me that much you know not that they hate
you but you know
they are very critical of you you know
yes i do know but with good reason
because then i started watching like 10
minutes of it and you do talk a lot
about politics and colbin and all
yeah because that's what i care about
you know right now okay but you're like
an entertainer
you didn't start off h3 as a political
commentary
so you're telling me basically to stay
in my lane
go back them critiquing girls and their
bikinis
you want me to call it tandem more
twinkie female quickie
more female twinkie jokes please i love
that content
this is [ __ ] disgust it's folding do
you see it's folding
are we gonna do hanukkah on their show
are we gonna give each other like gifts
for hanukkah
sure and jelly donuts
sufkani out yeah no yeah sufkanyam
hi thank you sorry i apologize
i'm very sorry about all this i'm sorry
you have such a crew here it's
impressive
you have so many people working for you
i have no banana no what the [ __ ]
should we see how far we can get it on
our feet all right
[Laughter]
all right you go first no you go first
that's the funny why you're a pro
okay wait no actually can i tell you
fair warning i'm not good
i'm not gonna blow jobs i'm not gonna
deep throating so literally i'm not like
it's
like this is a no one situation for me
and basically
like if i'm actually good at it then i
will never be forgiven for putting a
banana down my throat you'll probably be
let's see what you got
wow that's impressive oh my god you went
there girl where is it right here so you
have to bite it so we know where it's at
what if i just go fast and then bite it
real fast like
oh i don't know we can do that i'll do
that then okay well you go then no you
guys what if it breaks off with my
throat
i'm not this is like the gayest thing
i've ever done you mean
because i feel like i will never be
forgiven like the this will always be on
the internet
okay go dan who cares you deep throw a
banana dad
who cares you're gonna you're gonna deep
throw a banana dan
dan goes who cares go ahead give dan a
banana
give dan a banana he's going to deep
throat one after me
right just do it yourself
oh oh wow that's pretty good
yeah you beat me yeah
i think i got further where's my
lipstick oh i thought my lipstick was
gonna hit it
i get a little dan your turn
there's a banana right here oh there's
not ela's getting a banana for dan to
deep throat a big deal who cares
if i'm gonna be on the internet doing
that you are too [ __ ]
all right well let's eat some cheese on
a banana
what could be better than than room temp
it's starting to like con congealed
coagulate
yeah i've bad memories with this banana
it is it's awful you're such a baby real
so gross
oh my god this is so exciting
yeah right and bite down so we can see
how deep you got it
yeah make sure you see your throat yeah
wait wait wait the machine's covering
your face yeah come this way yeah yeah
oh yeah that's good all right you dirty
[ __ ] [ __ ]
wow wow holy [ __ ] i think you might have
won that little deeper
yeah dunk it in that and [ __ ] dirty
oh my god i would never want to work for
you ever
ever well humiliation is just you know
it's in the
it's in the uh engagements uh engagement
agreement what are you gonna do when dan
leaves you you know he's gonna get a
better paying
offer somewhere else that's just like
how i don't think so
that's like my best friend's work they
know he worked for h3 from the ground up
and so now they're gonna be like oh
we'll give you more money to come here
because we know you can do it
i think dan's getting paid pretty pretty
competitively
i know but that's why it happens that's
why you go to different companies so you
get more money you just keep switching
companies
been with howard for 40 years
you're con are you comparing him to baba
i'm just saying in the industry it's not
always
you know granted that your employees are
going to leave you for greener fields
this is a dream job right there friends
wait what's the what's the history on
this slice of pizza yeah
it's like look at this what the [ __ ] is
this
wait where does this come from maybe
just a straight slice of their finest
usually whole foods is so
bomb too but this cheese is have you
ever seen this is like rigor mortis
when you slap it like this was like
slapping it on a dip
you had to put the cheese on it
i'm not getting enough oh my gosh
okay oh my god this is
this is what it is this is how i feel
inside oh my god
oh my god oh my god
i hate the cheese it's just getting
grosser and grosser
the cheese is so gross it's ruining
everything um
oh it's just cold it's like cold the
pizza
this thing is fighting to stay alive
right now dude i'm on puke
you're gonna pee yeah that takes a lot
huh
i thought that i mean i thought you were
so in and now you're talking about
puking
because it's not five minutes ago you're
talking about what a baby i am you need
to be like in the car
eating hot food you don't do it like
here
what nothing this is horrible this might
be the worst i follow you
how do they get worse you put so much
effort into yourself sabotaging this you
want the show to get cancelled because
it was always
wow it's just funny because we put so
much effort into this
and it's just not good
the cheese is true you admit that jesus
discussed this yeah
now it is bring it in our next one
we have with us edible panties
oh well who are we
edible panties well they're to eat i'm
not putting them on and i urge you
and i would urge you not to play with
them on it either why
you know i've actually never actually
never actually seen edible banning what
so wait is the string edible how what is
this these are the only ones
it's just a big gummy yeah is the string
edible
no it's just a string i think this is
not for big people
let's see it's made from elastic yeah
let's see
can you oh my god actually you fit into
that
here
[Applause]
i like the lace as if you can't get
could you put it on
it off it broke already
do you want mine no no no
okay oh that one oh this one's hard
that looks like a vulva oh my god
can you imagine like there's gotta be
better sex activities than this
no this is everything girl girl put on
this [ __ ]
jump put on this that looks good
actually
does the dick go through yeah oh then oh
i see you're supposed to
yeah yeah no nothing not working go put
this [ __ ]
lifesaver over your vagina
how do you eat it oh you didn't put
cheese on it
see this feel this one like it's super
hard and this one's super soft like oh
that one's like 10 years old
that one's nice dip it in cheese
that tastes well no it's not that good
is that edible to the lace
no i tried wait really why would they
have that on there try it
i'm telling you it's not it's just lace
it's just place dude wait is it edible
i think no way it is yeah
oh my god what no
that's just fabric i don't think so
look you're going to eat that
nope that's just that's literally cotton
that's cotton i don't think something
all right we'll see it in your [ __ ] in a
couple of days
swallow everything you're gonna die no
you won't die you'll just [ __ ] out a
piece of coffee are you sure
oh yes i'm sure what if i actually die
that
sucks it's not edible oh you ate it too
so we died together
what did i eat it's in my hand you
didn't eat it
i've been holding it in front of this
whole thing okay did you dip it in the
cheese
yeah i didn't you're still wait
may i point out that she's still wearing
these oh i gotta wear this for a tick
tock this is so cool i love this
oh my god i can't wait to see the watch
time on this people tuned out in like 10
minutes this is awful
asmr ew
ew oh
that's so gross
ew it's just like
spinning you're a spitter huh damn you
spit a lot
next you'd be good make it quick i'm
done with this [ __ ] yeah i can't eat any
more gross i'm like kind of at my like
limit
my stuff no no no raw garlic
no we are not eating yeah we are
actually good for you right isn't it
good for you
i mean yeah it is but i'm getting is it
bad is it tastes bad i know
it's spicy it's spicy no it's a
it's a delicacy
oh my god cheers cheers let's not touch
oh i keep eating cheese everywhere
oh yeah it's spicy huh get your
get yeah
you don't feel that
i've never eaten a raw clove like that
okay it's kind of bad
you hit a banana to calm the spice
never heard of that
i think milk water makes it worse it's
not really spicy wait till we hit these
habaneros
i'm not doing it how much more [ __ ] do
we have because i'm like at my limit bro
how long we've been going dan
oh god we have to keep it right it's not
like the worst host of a podcast how you
have two i have no
three i have no idea five i have like
five just stop maybe
because you're about it yeah you're
literally like how much time have we
been at we got well no i
i just i don't want to eat more this
cheese is such a disaster
no one's like holding a gun to our head
it's your show no i'm gonna see it
through it just
i mean yes oh yes i'm looking at the
cheese and the
in the preview on dan's screen and i'm
glad it looks as disgusting as it
are yes my father is lebanese
would you ask me oh my god would you ask
him if he's middle eastern
i saw people no what how is that rude
he's lebanese were you offended by that
be honest
be honest in a way that i'm trying to
tell you oh my see this is not
i'm bringing my own employees i'm
bringing my employees next time so what
is this what is it just cake
with cheese on it you just cake why
wouldn't you put cheese on it
at the whole point the cheese is
supposed to be good the cheese is like
torture
at this point i mean this is just so
gross you guys it's the oh
it's not bad with the chocolate cheers
um
yeah honestly i would just eat this
chocolate cake because it's really good
five to uh three star michelin
he's a french three-star michelin that's
pretty good wow what is this
it's like fudge flourless
whole whole foods finest
yum gordon ramsay don't have [ __ ]
[ __ ] on this
gordon ramsay's a [ __ ] he doesn't know
how to cook are you ever sad that you're
just
caucasian and not mixed with anything
exciting
i thought i was jewish i thought it was
exciting no i think that's still
considered white
so that's the that's the kind of the
paradox of being jewish right like
if you ask a white supremacist as jewish
being white they'd be like [ __ ] no
wait really what are you then but then
if you ask
like if you ask like a black lives
matter or like
someone who's like on the far left
spectrum of like identity politics and
stuff they would say
jews are white they are you're caucasian
what else do you mark when you go to the
dmv
i think i'm yeah i think i'm caucasian
but like if you ask a um
you think you're a minority no no no i
don't have a minority i don't feel like
a minority a lot of jews do
it depends where you live you know in
california i'm not a minority you know
tick-tock comes from me because they
think i'm being like
mean to jews yeah you are but i don't
i'm not offended i say you got beef with
this [ __ ] tick tock account
you crazy oh they did another one today
i came for them i was like i was like
first of all you crazy you are [ __ ]
jew crazy
no and they they dress they present
themselves as orthodox jews but
orthodox jews are not supposed to have
phones or tv i'm pretty sure they're
conservative not orthodox
no they're not in there they have this
platform i'm pretty sure they know
better their rules of life than you know
i have also a jew in my household so
yeah but moses is [ __ ]
jewish he agrees well hold on there if
they're conservative they can use
technology
well don't you well they're making up
their own rules on the fly they're jew
crazy dude
thank you i'm actually going to convert
to judaism like he's not jewish but i'm
going to convert dude if you convert
that'd be the ultimate slam dunk
i'd be like yo crazy i'm [ __ ] jewish
now [ __ ]
no i'm 100 i'm not even joking it's not
hard it's not easy though converting to
judaism is real adam stanley's wife did
it
yeah well moses said adam sandler he's
better
just kidding adam sandler if you're
listening i love you more well i don't
love you more but i i
would rather you see how you're getting
all crazy even at the thought
what's next next this was my favorite
actually
this one was good i'll go for another
one god you know what i did you tell me
this or did i just come to realize that
i'm sorry
that theodore is a double jew he's
ashkenazi and the other one
that's cool i agree he's like eugene
lovey
yep that's sick who's that from [ __ ]
baby
he's iconic i hope he doesn't die before
i meet him i love him
oh oreos my fave oh my god
i missed theodore today oh do we not
mention him you don't mention your child
right sorry
cut it edit it he exists what am i
denying that he exists
i have family members that don't want me
to mention them ever so how is it
awful i hate it
i don't want to ever eat this cheese i
ever eat cheese again maybe this is good
for me because
um i feel like cheese ruined my life
mind you it makes me who i am in a bad
way
and i feel like maybe maybe there's a
type of therapy where you get
overexposed to something and then you
hate it you know
no there totally is that therapy um it
seems like inhumane but i'm down for it
they're like oh you like smoking huh
well why don't you smoke
this whole pack until you fight you know
what i mean it's like that
your hands are good mood it's so funny
i love it interesting comment you're so
happy today
i'm pretty i'm feeling quite miserable
can i ask you i'm gonna ask you a
question since we're having some down
time here
i have more oreos without the cheese
dude i'm not your boss you're too crazy
so here crazy too we have that in common
so you wanna
let's go over the juke crazy drama wait
is it on your notes or do you just uh
huh
wait really they told oh they
they came at you and they said they
actually came at you moses
if anybody probably did did we see that
one well because they said
they said you know according to the
torah you're not uh non-jew or jews are
not supposed to
date non or be married to non-jews
thank you so much for being writing our
videos super cool by the way
they should be called
and you're entitled to that opinion and
you will probably have that opinion by
the end of this video however
we'd like to give you a quick education
god gave the tour to the jewish people
it's also known as the old testament
which is mainly comprised of the five
books of moses
which are known as genesis exodus
leviticus numbers in deuteronomy
there are many commandments in the torah
from monetary loss and dietary laws to
modesty
and one of those commandments clearly
states that it's prohibited for a jew to
marry an anju
have a great day trisha first of all
we're not married we're just [ __ ]
right now
or dating but also having sex out there
oh i think jews can [ __ ] boy
they just can't marry him is that why
we're not getting married this sucks
whoa they're so stupid yeah but like
it's like dude you're going to talk
about the old testament rules like
oh jews can't marry non-jews it's like
bro are you like [ __ ] stoning gay
people to death too like what's going on
and here's the other thing if you don't
believe that
he's not going to hell because you don't
believe in it so what's what happens if
you date a non-jew marry nanju
right uh crazy maybe you commit the
follow-up video does god drop a [ __ ]
bible on you like what the [ __ ] happens
if you marry a non-jew that's the stupid
thing i've heard they don't believe in
hell it's [ __ ] dumb
i think there's like different levels of
heaven
there's no hell but there's different
levels of like heaven
they don't get the oh well that's not
the worst in my room it's like you want
to be balling in after life or you want
to be like
oh like you know you know
in the afterlife can i say that no you i
don't think you're a slave but you're
like i think so
what are you a [ __ ] scholar yeah
because no in beetlejuice when you kill
yourself you're a slave
in the afterlife like you have to work
for them like if you kill yourself did
you say like in beetlejuice
you know what i mean and
thank you actually it's very shit's
creek inspired warrior rose i have
assisted
which is not a costume but by the way
for christmas i am wearing a costume
i'm going to be cindy lou who so i'm
just letting you know ahead of time so
you don't think i didn't tell you
about my themes are you listening to me
wait why are you leaving yeah leave
those
oh no i'm not listening why am i you're
talking about shit's creek you're like
blah
blah
blah blah blah i'm trying to do a show
these episodes in christmas and you just
missed the whole thing what i was going
to tell you go ahead
no you're missing so i'll watch it
nobody tell him because
i said what we're doing what i'm doing
in december but i'm not telling you
anything because you come for all my
ideas and then you make it to a
competition and you're like oh my god
you're jealous i have a better outfit
nothing what is just oh you're wearing a
costume yeah
wow i could never thank god so is this
the last one
thank god congrats on teddy fresh i feel
like i should tell ela that cause i feel
like she's the only person that does
teddy fresh right you don't really work
for it
i work for time you design yeah i do
sometimes you go to the office i don't
think you do i never hear you about
going into refresh
well well not these days i used to go
more i will once we move to our next
year can we have a frenemies hoodie like
a pink and black one
no you don't give me money i'm not
asking for a cut
i'm just saying it'd be cool
so we order a bunch of frenemy's hoodies
they're bomb as [ __ ] and then in three
months the show gets cancelled but
people still buy it in eight months from
now
that's iconic yum frenemies hoodie
we haven't had a show in five months i
would wear it that'd
be sick no you wouldn't not if you hated
me you know
this cheese is no longer flowing i'd
like to point out
it's like a candle you know when it
dries
i love that juke crazy was a topic for
you here's what i want to do
let's see let's take let's let's grab a
habanero
let's end this off right and i'll ask
you questions as we settle on these
habaneros
are dipping in cheese or we're just
doing habanero no in the cheese what are
we what
what are we doing here just eating
habaneros it might lessen the blow
i don't think anything's going to lessen
the blow are they bad are these bad
well you can buy them at rales i'll put
that to you that way but do like a whole
thing like down to like this much
really i'm bad with my ted come just the
tip
oh it's already hot i'm not doing that
um
oh it's back come on you gotta join me
i'm gonna i'm getting like this right
like this much
i mean that's pretty much all of it
that's why you get 55
i get 45 i don't have to do a part of
the work it's actually really good with
it tastes really good it's not good oh
that's really hot i don't like it the
flavor is really good with the cheese
i'm really bad spicy actually i'm really
bad with spicy that's not good
okay
so the thing is i've eaten a lot of
spicy food
yeah and usually you get like dried or
the concentrated oh my god what's wrong
with you
this is really my thrill right now and
i've been i've gotten hot ones and i've
done like the atomic burger on hot ones
which is actually coming on tuesday wait
what
who's coming on i did a hot ones with
like the spiciest burger in the world a
real one
the guy or you did it on your own no
with the guy on the channel
yeah how come i didn't get him on there
with you well we should actually shot it
like
half a year ago i went on as a duo can i
come on as a duo with you
you're taking all the good opportunities
and not just sharing them with me we
shot it a long time ago
if it comes up again you met me i don't
know what the [ __ ]
i feel like this is what's gonna happen
you're gonna get offered like a spot
like regis and kelly
and you're gonna just bring someone else
i feel like it wasn't that bad it tasted
really good
do you want to eat more with me like i'm
talking to a wall you don't listen to
anything i say
okay you think that i'm going to go
become regis feldman and you're going to
be left in the trenches
yeah you're going to take like i justine
or somebody right now you're implying
that you made me or something
no but i'm saying like oh we really love
frenemies ethan i would
i i would bring you with me if someone
was like oh we only want you church i'm
like no
would you bring me yeah you would yeah
then let's bring
each other all the way
oh my god
then you don't like it dan all right let
me ask you ques that wasn't as spicy as
i thought
i don't know i was spicy i thought that
was way too spicy yeah i'm totally fine
now actually
kind of a big shot in the spicy world
uh we talked about you crazy that's the
topic that's so funny
trisha you don't you made you turned a
new leaf you erased all your
problematic videos yeah good job
thank you you erased your uh by your
personality
uh what is it called borderline or id
yeah d-i-d
yeah you erased your trans video
and you made an apology yeah i probably
was a step in the right direction for
people
trying to like see that i'm sincere i
feel like you've been getting a lot of
good um
good vibes from from yeah i know
i find it weird that you would be be
getting depressed because i feel like
it's all good vibes for you right i know
that's that's the thing about depression
it just it happens when everything's
going good you still feel like [ __ ]
but also it's kind of but also it's like
yeah i in a way you know what i think it
is it's like a way of trying to
self-sabotage
because it's like you you you have this
you know my my therapist described it
it's like a rubber band you know
it's like when you get into too
comfortable of a space
because your natural state is like
depression and
misery or whatever i'm being you know
whatever it's like you you
your tendency to rubber band back
because you feel so uncomfortable
being content right
that's kind of on par with what my
therapist tells me he tells me i'm so
used to chaos and he's like you're
comfortable in chaos so when things are
calm and good you just want to create
chaos
but you have to get used to order
because it's better
yeah you have to start to just feel
comfortable
in order i was chaos this weekend i was
really bad this weekend and i feel
really bad about it
what happened what'd you do i don't know
i got a big fight
a one-sided bite with moses
well he seems okay are you okay we
haven't talked about it because i didn't
want to cry
really but i don't want to come here
along cause i'm like they're gonna know
something's wrong so come with me
oh damn
i hope you guys work it out i like you
guys but he knows
but like well i i don't know the content
of the
i wasn't mean or physical art well i no
i wasn't mean at all i was really sad
actually the banana fell well i'm sorry
to hear that you know i i don't know
obviously don't know the content of the
fight but like it wasn't a fight
well i i don't mean a physical i mean
you guys obviously had a verbal
altercation right
um i'm just me it's always one-sided
because moses is so calm he's the worst
person to fight with because he's just
so
i'm like just leave he's like that's
annoying right the same it's like it's
so annoying they're just like
[ __ ] they're just chill with
whatever you want they're like all right
that's awful i hope you guys work it out
you feel like maybe maybe it won't work
out
oh moses said i love her
i know yeah i was like i don't love you
oh that's [ __ ] up
i know buck i'm i know unless you mean
it no i think i love so you wanted to
break up with him and he was like is
that what it was
yeah and he's like okay i'll just leave
and then i wanted to fight more but he
already left
damn he's like can i sleep in the bat
i'm like no i'll sleep in the gas room
and then he went back to his place last
night those first night we slept alone
in three months and i was really sad and
that's why i'm really impressed
well that's why you're depressed then
i was depressed last week
well if you do like him you guys can
work it out look at this thing working
its way down man
this is your this is a metaphor for like
your relationship yeah because like
here's normality here's stability and
it's like it's a slow ascent
but like i mean descent i mean but like
you know
you just gotta handle you just gotta
hold on for the ride or your life
i'm like the habanero on top riding the
dick
i'm hoping i don't follow you bob lane
yeah this is awesome this is by far our
best show
one time oh that's cool ew
oh my god if that thing falls and hits
me it's so crazy
oh my god stop it's gonna it's gonna
like bust
stop okay there's so much anger in you
right now
you're at the beginning of our
relationships moses told me i gave
toothy [ __ ]
say what he said i used too much teeth
and blow jobs oh he told you that well
that's good feedback
i was right you didn't get that feedback
by now in your life that's what i said
i'm like no one's ever complaining
i'm surprised you're the first person to
tell me that that's all i think about
now so i hold it against him i told him
that in our fight
you know what i fell out of love with
you when you told me i had toothy
[ __ ]
why that's like good feedback i don't i
don't say if someone's doing something
wrong well hold on was it like yo stop
don't ever get it was it mean or was it
like just say you
yeah it's constructive feedback no this
is how he said it can i tell you
he's like oh do you always use so much
teeth
that's not super direct
that's the most embarrassing thing
that's ever happened and i still hold
resentment
towards him today because you thought
maybe that she was like a kinky into
like teeth play or something
yeah i think i've given that feedback to
someone before but like because it's
like you're in a relationship
and you're like yo like just you so you
know
because sometimes they say how is it you
go well there's a lot of teeth
down there i think that's good feedback
he wants damned a catfish that my [ __ ]
stink
say that again he once dm'd a fake girl
that he never met that was a catfish we
thought it was catfishing him with fake
photos she was actually a big fat [ __ ]
from chicago and was catfishing him as a
skinny supermodel
and he texted her trisha's [ __ ] smelled
so bad i'd never desire sex with her
you said that
oh really should we bring up should we
bring up the textbook but
wait wait no no no no because why are
you keep going back i thought you were
over this stuff
i'm not over it you want to go back and
look at it
so he's like his reply was well her
[ __ ] was sick so i didn't want to go
down on her that was his reply and you
know what that's why i don't want to sex
with him right now so i was like i told
him
oh wait this is like old i thought this
was water under the bridge yeah you
can't keep going back to this
trisha you can't keep going back it
lives in my head like i talked to my
therapist about it about the [ __ ]
comment about him saying my [ __ ] was
you can't get over the
face thing that i can get over but him
talking to a catfish and trash about me
like
is your vagina this is a different
catfish by the way no my vagina is so
clean well just
by the way clean and i didn't say your
dick was cheesy or anything i was just
should i turn this off because i wonder
if it's just a really annoying sound
well it's been through the whole video
so it's like continuity but okay
continuity people are like thank god
wait so anyway you can have a clean but
stinky vagina like i've been with girls
who are not stinky
moms
oh he was hurt so he told a catfish but
that's kind of sweet he's like you hurt
my feelings
you hurt my feelings so i told this
random girl in the dms that i think
anyone would see that her vagina stinks
yeah because he got catfished by the
same girl three times he's so stupid
that is pretty ridiculous
by the way what's wrong with this girl
what a freak and i proved to him that
she's been stalking me for like 10 years
because there's a guru gossip website
that has her instagram account because
she's like girl she's obsessed with you
she deleted the
names her fake name was lily liu her
real name's melissa and she's been like
stalking all my boyfriends for 10 years
and i showed him on this website
why did she stalk your boyfriend i don't
know but this one is stupid enough to be
like oh can't wait to put my nose in
your [ __ ]
three times two by hurt one by one of
your fans the other the
chick that watches your the other
300-pound catfish from that watches your
show
from northern california you've seen
like on on uh on 90 day fiance the other
way they
always have these ones where they go i
got catfish but i stayed with them oh
yeah jenny
we love them that's so funny we got
catfish twice by him and then he was
married on top of that
guy it's like some jack like beautiful
model and then the real guy is like some
basement dwelling indian dude which is
like missing teeth
and she's like i loved him yeah yeah i
love that story though that's kind of
everything i feel like that was him with
the catfishes because he defended them
until we finally figured out until they
exposed him and then he's like all right
maybe that was a bad idea
but he says your [ __ ] doesn't sink you
know what started so why does that
bother you he said you're put
he says your [ __ ] doesn't stink i was
hurt doesn't that help yeah that helps
but what triggered all of this was
friday night he logged me out of his
instagram
and he always had ever since she didn't
show me her ideas
for christmas i might as well just say
it because you already ruined it why do
you want i need to see your dms
can you mike moses
okay he's just okay basically i'll tell
you what happened so just give him a mic
i'll just tell you what happened well
because people can't hear you it's fine
okay
i lit i was like i had my
because i yeah let's let's mike moses so
because like let's get to the bottom of
this
thank you yeah yeah
show me her dms and i said i thought in
my mind
you know what i'm going to log her out
and when she asked me to log in i'll ask
her
i want your login too so we both log
into each other that's all
i'm not the one texting people behind us
why did you want to see her dms why did
you want to see her at dms
show it to me and usually she does
because
for christmas i already gave him his
christmas present because he was going
to leave and i was going to break up
with him i'm like you might as well have
this because i got him a brand new
iphone a blue one and it had his phone
number already attached to it so i got a
custom
case made with his water like an acrylic
painting of his
work and so i didn't want to show him
because he knew all the presents i
already got him for his birthday he knew
the laptop for christmas he knew the
iphone something
why were you not all of a sudden letting
him see your dms because that's why i
was dming i was dming about his gift and
he knew every single gift i've given him
up until that point
and i was like this is something that he
doesn't know i'm doing for him so did
you let him in your dms or not yet
no because then that night we just
turned around and the next day i left
and i said just leave but then and then
you wanted to look at his dms and then
he was saying
she thought i did something shady
because you logged her out someone found
him on hinge that night someone found
him on hinge
and i was like let me see your dms and
he logged me out that night wait why did
someone find you on hinge
i deactivated my account long time ago
and for some reason they still showed it
so then in front of her eyes i opened it
it was logged out but then logged
he just said he loves you he just said
he loves you every guy says that maybe
no but moses isn't on hinge he's not
people
he locked me out of that account moses
isn't a cheater i i wouldn't
i don't think coincidence that those two
things happen at the same time although
i understand why she's skeptical of your
explanation because if
i wouldn't expect to see your account on
hinge if you deactivated it
me neither that's exactly the point
of her why did you see it on hinge that
account is back
oh that's [ __ ] cycle it's ruining
your life
don't listen to anything she does she's
ruining your [ __ ] life
are you sure you're not like tyler
durden from fight club and you wake up
in the night and that's you hurt you're
her
don't say i've long suspected that it's
you
you have like tyler dirt and ruining
your [ __ ] all your life she dropped
my phone i was doing my spelling t oh i
don't want to say a [ __ ]
can i give you like jerry's what's what
jerry sign or
jerry seinfeld jerry [ __ ] what was
what's spring or he has his final
thoughts okay yeah final cut
jerry's final thoughts you gotta love
how he tries to get fi he's like okay
everybody fight and ruin your [ __ ]
life now let me give my final thoughts
that's okay
why what is with you guys why are you so
distrustful of each other
you're looking in her dms moses this is
unbecoming of you what is this
you don't trust her you don't trust him
you're in each other's dms this is
this this is this is outrageous childish
behavior you guys are in love
it's quite obvious you both care about
each other what is with the skepticism
i never even checked his dms when i got
his password i was like you know what
this is all i needed
so the night he logged me out and it was
the same night of hinge the same right
that account came back
and then he logged me out and i was like
the next thing he's ready why'd you log
her up
just for revenge
ah you log her out i can see why she got
paranoid you know she's sensitive
sure like i said i'm sorry so have you
let her enter your dm's
again i have nothing to hide that's the
thing and then i realized that's when i
realized i didn't care anymore i was
like you know what i don't care let's
just break up
well i think that's drastic because i
literally didn't care he's like here's
my password i'm like no you did that
like i [ __ ] don't care i actually
don't care
so that's why i was like all alright i'm
over it but i think the key is to not
care about what's in each other's dms
no because he has proven time i've
always told him i was always up front
hey i'm sleeping with somebody i'm doing
this before we started dating he was
always like i talk to no girls i never
talk to girls that way
all of a sudden i want to put my nose in
your [ __ ] trisha's [ __ ] stinks can't
wait to [ __ ] you wanna cuddle you
could be you this little [ __ ] kitten
in my arms like he's doing all these oh
here's my boob shot that's what he
texted a girl
shot no but it's not like that you sent
your tits to some girl
all of those takes were when i was
single before we were dating but you
always said oh i don't talk to girls
that way and then i was like
this is so cringe oh my god like that
makes me want to gag
this is what he sent her but this is
what she does she's all day on those
messages she obsessed with those
messages
there's nothing special about it how
about these ones
i like everything about you hold on hold
on
you don't need to humiliate you don't
need to humiliate why he did it to me
him he told me my [ __ ] was stinks the
point he
said he says he doesn't he doesn't think
that okay well
how are you guys going to get up past
this i'm past this
i'm not yeah ethan she's
for sure wait nobody can hear you ela
say it into the mic
this microphone is really getting
important from from mukbang to
[ __ ] emo shebang this is an emotional
saying that sometimes people will say
really mean stuff
not to your face because you're not
supposed to see that stuff and the fact
that you guys are obsessing over
reading everything you always say you're
reading all of these chats
it's just really unhealthy it's not
going to end well if you want to or not
because
it's not meant for you to read no it's
it's gonna sound to you so mean but he
would never say something like that to
your face that's worse though because
things i said i said i knew he would
watch my podcast i
never have said anything nasty behind
his back everything i've said i've said
to his face so that's even worse when
someone says it behind well it's
old though he hasn't done anything like
that since you guys have been together
but new ones keep coming out all the
time like those new
that one came on october 9th october 9th
but it's old it's from old
moses hasn't done anything like that
since you guys have been together do you
acknowledge that
yeah okay good so that's good
that's good right he hasn't done
anything like that since you guys have
been steady dating
yeah now he says you [ __ ] ten guys
well you guys we weren't dating we
weren't dating i texted one girl
no three one girl three catfishes you
thought that you were sexing three
different girls period of time did you
sleep with ten guys how long was that
um may through july wow
exactly no reason to slush shame someone
yes i'm honest you know what it is i'm
honest with him i'm like yeah i was up
with people he was oh i don't even talk
to any other girl so as he was he just
lies like that's my issue
at least be [ __ ] honest about it like
i was honest would you say to that
no because i was single but you were
lied about it you said you didn't on the
way down to my dad you're like i never
text any other girl that was a troll and
i trolled the back that's
okay he got the trolling i'm back in the
private deal
i was trolling back you know okay she's
like i'm coming to see you okay
i think the most important thing is that
he hasn't done anything like that since
you guys have been steady
right and i think that's really all that
matters he's still defending that though
it's like he really thinks he did
nothing wrong like
literally is totally fine he goes oh i
was trolling her saying why do you i
just don't know why you keep going back
to that because i can't get past it and
i do i have talked to therapist about it
and i literally can't get past it and
i'm just like
it sucks it sucks because it sticks in
my head and it's like the worst thing
ever
how can you guys how can you how can you
make it right for you
i have no idea like that's the thing i
don't think he can like it's already in
my head
those those words stuff about that your
[ __ ] stinks yeah that i can't control
my eating and like all this stuff like
really personal stuff he told people
he's like yeah she has issues with food
she's high she's obsessed with me like
it's good crazy [ __ ] that sticks in my
head and like
i want to get past it because i have so
much fun with moses i love him so much
and it's just like
i can't get past it like i just it's
like the first time in my life where i
like i don't wanna have sex with someone
because i'm just like oh like he thinks
my [ __ ] stinks oh he thinks i have a
issue with food like do you notice why
like sometimes you care about it
sometimes you don't do you notice why
sometimes you do and sometimes you don't
is there something that triggers it i
guess him logging me out of the
instagram then i started not trusting
you start having negative feelings and
it brings all that stuff up
yeah and then i went to that account
that post all the dm's and i thought
that they dm me october 9th and i was
like oh my god there's more there's
always more you gotta block that person
you really gotta just block that person
they're [ __ ] your life up there just
but it's stuff that i want to have known
otherwise because he doesn't tell me i
tell him everything i'm like yeah i [ __ ]
jaymore like you know what i mean i tell
him everything oh he gave me an american
express credit card have sex with him
you know i'd say everything but like
even though you know it it's not
necessarily something that represents
his true feelings
you know that's kind of what you know
worse no that's what i'm saying i think
it's worse when it's private and hidden
it's one thing to say it like on a
podcast because my feelings are hurt so
i'm like well [ __ ] him he can't even eat
[ __ ]
but like it's one thing to say it
privately like what if i dmd privately
and i was like oh wow moses has a cheesy
[ __ ] like it's so disgusting it was more
like he was just kind of
venting to some random person it doesn't
really mean
that he believes that i'm just i mean i
could speak from experience sometimes
you say stuff
sometimes you say stuff that's really
nasty and then when you're done with the
conversation you go wow i
i don't believe anything i just said
that was like super over the top and
nasty you ever had that experience
i just i've never said anything like
nasty like that privately about him like
and not even publicly i never say
anything nasty i like about him like his
looks or his appearance or anything
moses sent you a text saying that i go
with underage girls
no inappropriate age girls oh my god
well i can go back to that if you want
to go back and he read it but i think
but i think it's out to the world
but hold on i think that you you clearly
have you clearly are able to get over
things better than her right we can say
that
yeah of course so
i think that you know it's it's tough
because like
you guys have obviously done hurtful
things to each other and it's
you you have a you're able to get over
them easier so it's
so you have to be careful not to hold
her to that same standard because
for some reason it's just she she gets
hung up on things
more i mean the way i see it is that if
you really love someone you can forgive
them
and if you forgive them you forget i
forgive them but i can't forget it don't
forget it so you're not saying no every
time you have sex i think oh my [ __ ]
stinks you trying to go down on me i'm
like no my [ __ ] things don't do i
literally stop you i'm like stop because
it like makes me uncomfortable when i
tell you that i'm because this makes me
so uncomfortable like stop
because i think about that comment and
so i can't forget it's not that it's not
that i don't forgive you and i know you
probably said it because you were hurt
or whatever but it's so
it stings so bad because no one's ever
said that so it's like [ __ ]
awful like we only have sex like every
few days now because i'm like i don't
even crave it i don't even want it
because i feel so and it like sticks in
my head it really does and i do talk to
therapists about it
and they're like well if you can't let
it go which like just like cheating if
you can't forgive someone fully you
can't move forward you have to just
break up if you can fully forgive
someone then you can try and work on it
whatever
then i like just fully can it has
nothing to do with like i'm so sad
without you like that's why i called you
because i was like [ __ ] i'm so dependent
on him now and i'm like but
it just sucks because i'm so like i have
so much hate in me still for like hate
for him and it sucks
because i don't want to be that way not
necessarily hate but like maybe
resentment yeah
that's the same i don't think it's the
same
moses you can either love everyone or
hate everyone there's no one between
them like that's not what i hate
i disagree i mean look you you took a
lot of trauma
clearly and things take time to process
and
you know see how you feel about it and
to get through it i don't think
things are so binary as as you're
describing
you say you say you can either
you have to forgive and forget or would
you say
yeah if you forgive you forget i hate
hispanics i don't
spend every day thinking about the stuff
she did i don't know you have to
acknowledge that you
your brain your attitude the way you you
conduct yourself is not the same that
she does and you can't just expect her
to be
you right no i don't that's why i'm
still around and i'm trying and i say
everything i can
to make up for it yeah so
but one time i said something negative
but for three months i'm saying
everything thinks positive she doesn't
hold on to that she only holds to the
one negative thing that happened
months ago she won't let it go well yeah
i mean it is
it was hard feeling yeah i really want
to try and let it go because like
moses is like the best person on paper
he's calm he has his own job he likes me
he's into me like i like him like it's
perfect
but that's why i am trying to let it go
it's not like do you think maybe well do
you think maybe you're just trying to
self-sabotage
it's like you're clinging on to
something really negative that happened
a few months ago
and you're like you won't let this thing
go even though he's been really good
since you guys have been steady he's
been he hasn't made those same mistakes
so it's like you're like i have to
obsess over this one
thing that's going to try to sour this
relationship that's otherwise you know
idyllic it's like a self-sabotage it's
more just like i feel like i will never
be able to trust him and like he can't
do anything to fix that
it's literally on me like i can't get
over it you don't you think that it's
you don't acknowledge that maybe it's a
self-sabotage
i don't think so because i really do
talk to a therapist and like i don't
think it is in this because i really
want it to work out
so bad like so so bad
so i don't i i hope not i just like if
it's something i really can't get over
i don't want to have this like when he
shows me a tick tock i'm like it sucks
you know because i just want him to feel
like hurt too you know what i mean like
i want him to have a bruised ego like i
have a bruisy and that's like not
healthy for him you're upset yeah
i see you're just resentful all the time
yeah and i've been not all the time but
like
just recently like you guys got in the
fight so maybe you guys just needed some
time to kind of let things cool and then
yeah and then maybe once these negative
feelings settle
then you won't be just constantly
thinking because it's like you you get
these negative feelings
and when they trigger then you like you
go back to like
the time he hurt you the most and so
yeah cause i didn't think about it i
think you need to let it settle out of
the instagram and then all of a sudden i
was like oh
okay back to the fake the hiding the dms
not being truthful i was like what the
[ __ ] like it was weird
i think that's important to remember
yeah going forward
because like one doesn't have anything
to do with the other but you're
associating them just because
you're mad at him so i think maybe just
let it settle and then
i wouldn't make any rash decisions
because let's let's be honest we all
ship you two
we ship it hard i feel like i'd quit the
podcast if we broke up like i almost
couldn't what
why would you quit the podcast because i
don't want to see
you know she looks like moses what
that's stupid wait i have to recoup what
the [ __ ] you talking about already
i think you did maybe barely but so that
means you made a bunch of money and i
recouped what kind of [ __ ] is that
yeah well i took more like traumatic
experiences on the show like dr drew
like was in on me
yeah i feel like ever like that was
really good and everyone's like i'm team
trisha now
oh i didn't get that vibe
you're not quitting this [ __ ] show
you're just complaining about how i'm
gonna go be regis filming and leave your
ass in the trenches
you're still gonna let me on if i break
if you will just break up yeah what do i
care
oh [ __ ] i mean it seems like
it seems like you guys are being mature
about it and to the extent that like
you guys if you guys break up you can
have
you can separate amicably it's not like
you know he's like what what the [ __ ]
you guys
yeah yeah cause that would have been so
weird one it's just weird anyways i hate
coming here
before the podcast it's so awkward
you're the most
i never mind what you're just so
unwelcoming and that's why i need moses
here so i can go hide and i told him i
was like can you just go hide with me
somewhere because this is so awkward
why literally never talk to me unless
we're on the podcast
what i'm like where's theodore oh no
he's probably somewhere i'm walking
what was i doing when you were talking
what was i doing talking to other people
talking to anyone but
no i was cooking i was prepping for this
nightmare
that's [ __ ] you can't say i'm
unwelcome man you're not personable
well i don't like i'm doing stuff i'm
not like okay everybody
trish is here nobody talk to me maybe
just like a hello would be nice
i'm pretty sure i gave you a very warm
welcome you definitely never do
i was like hey trisha you did it
replay the cameras in your kitchen do
you have cameras out there
no oh should i
yeah anyway look at your side disgusting
mine is a little cleaner i'm sad to hear
that you guys are fighting i don't like
it
and i hope you guys can work it out we
come back engaged we're getting married
that's kind of your life isn't it just
kidding oh he got mad
you're still wearing edible panties
maybe you and moses can can uh
maybe the scent will be ma
would be covered by the by uh canty
panties canty panties all right
well just that's it
throwing it out there he got mad because
i bought a ring that looked like an
engagement ring and he's like well if i
was gonna get you one then it's not
anyways that's a whole other thing too
we better go dan's going to have a
hernia over there if we go over 30
an hour and a half i don't know why
you're so upset i mean we're having a
conversation dan gets
dan gets really upset when we go super
wait why does he
i'm assuming it's because he we're on a
tight schedule we started late he wants
to get it rated so we can get it up
tomorrow
which is all really good yeah what do
you have to do tomorrow
we're we're filming a content choir
maybe just cut a couple podcasts
no why we're not all bangers no
so but we're here for the people we work
for the people focus on
quality over quantity like this then he
wouldn't be stressed about
this podcast that's amazing and gets
over a million views every episode to go
to content court which is great if
that's your passion project but at the
same
time let's focus on what makes money you
know so just for enemies that you're
saying you're gonna quit
you're gonna quit next week all right
you can replace me
if you're quitting i gotta do i gotta
buy you guys a therapist or something i
gotta make sure you guys get married
because i don't want this to stop
you can replace me with keemstar you can
just be friend of me can you i wouldn't
[ __ ] sit in the same room as though
you guys were he was on the podcast yeah
that was a long time ago
you think you you do it you wanted to be
on your podcast on the h31
yeah he's desperate to be my friend how
come he has more clout than frenemies
everybody wants to be on that podcast
why don't you want to be on irons
to be a part of this i mean can i come
on h3 sometime soon oh so next um
the podcast yeah we're doing a
personality test for the whole game
on h3 yeah and i think when dr drew's
next available be in this
early december so we're all and
including both you guys even if you
break up or not you're both gonna be on
it
i thought about that all of us lina you
should do one too
dan get lena a uh a personality test
is she is she oh yeah are you new so we
never met hi i'm trisha you're married
she works for teddy fresh okay so we do
have some females up in here remember i
said you don't hire females well we have
a lot of females in teddy fresh
a little sexist to have them in the
clothing department and not the podcast
department
um okay
i guess that's the way it is yeah bring
it up to hr tell
uh tell it to your therapist do you
think i'm catfishing in my phone case
does that look like me or do you think
it's catfish
i mean it i feel like you're fit like i
feel like you look more [ __ ] up there
oh thank you because your eyes it looks
like somebody pushed your eyes away from
each other
i don't know what happened thank you
let's see what happens now
let's do one final push for the road
take some of that cheese with that
banana
you want it to go back for anything i
want you to eat it right now
you wanted to go back for the nuggets or
the cheese or anything no
are you guys gonna talk it out what are
you gonna do now it was so awkward on
the way over i'm like don't talk to me
because we're gonna cry
so i just you guys should work it out
awkward
on the way home i guess you should go
get them some mcdonald's or something i
think chick-fil-a because they have a
peppermint shake i said we could try
that after go to chick-fil-a that sounds
great that's a good place to
bury the hatch the nugget
[Music]
let's wrap it up eh why is it the a i
don't know
we meet alone and he hasn't been pulling
out so we've been like trying to get
you that's great your life is in such a
[ __ ] mess
i'm breaking up i hate him he's not
pulling out
never since ever since the past two
weeks no pull out
is that because you want to get her
pregnant
oh that's just nodding yes
because he says he has to have intent
behind it i'm like oh do you have intent
now and he just said yes
he's trying but don't put but like you
guys are on the rocks and you're trying
to knock her up
we're not on the rocks oh you're not i
feel like we'll always be together
oh moses saying yes probably i mean i
don't know it's only been 24 hours
do you hope that getting her pregnant
will somehow trap me
that is not true that'll fix the
relationship
oh yeah i do say that because it's hard
to get pregnant for getting pregnant
it's really hard and he goes not with me
he's so he's so determined
it's not true all right this i don't
know what to do maybe we'll be pregnant
we're gonna stop should we do a live
pregnancy test if i'm a week late i was
a week late once i thought i was right
now so sad
sure if you're late we can do a levy
awesome fine if you're late cool
gilas are you late you know not yet oh
this is so exciting we'll do one
together
i'll go on the h3 pack can i pick an ip
on a stick keep my brightness
all right let's go danielle hates me
he's like that is not amused
see ya that's it thank you to
adamandeve.com
use code h3 for 50 off let's free
shipping and handling get six free
toys and 10 free movies use h3